Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones. You can talk
to me when we take live calls via Discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's go
to Oh, I don't know. How about let's go to
Jack from Indianapolis first today, Jack,
you're on the air. What's on your mind?
Jack from Indianapolis, please.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. So I got a couple
of questions for you. The first one would be have
you done any research at all into the way in which
music or art subcultures influence politics?
Speaker 1: Not, not as a general topic. I mean,
I've read and seen documentaries about
specific musical movements, for example,
or what have you and its connection to
politics, but not as a general topic.
Speaker 4: Oh, okay. Yeah, I just
find that whole kind of realm to be
fascinating personally, just the way in which
different genres have their own kind of political
leanings, most of them are left wing. Yes, there
is the occasional right leaning scene as well.
Speaker 1: When do you think
country's leading to the left
country music in the U.S. tends to be more right
wing, with exceptions, of course. You know,
the Dixie Chicks would be an exception, and
there's others. But country music in the
U.S. certainly is has more of a right wing bent.
Speaker 4: Mm hmm. Yeah. And even in recent years,
country music has kind of started leaning more
left. You know, I've heard rumors that more of the
country artists in general tend to be more left
leaning than people think. Interesting. It's more
like kind of private for them, I guess, though.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, it also maybe
it's private because it would be bad
for their ticket sales if it was public.
Speaker 4: Yeah, exactly. But also there's I
mean, there's like things like black metal and,
you know, like death metal tend to have more
kind of right leaning, but like libertarian
ideologies versus like, you know, punk rock
has always been very hard left. But yeah,
you know, the occasional right wing
strand like straight edge culture
sometimes is right wing, I don't know. Anyway, I
just found that whole thing kind of interesting.
And I guess the second question would be,
you know, you're a drummer, right? Yes.
Where can I listen to some of your playing?
Speaker 1: Oh, I don't know that there is any.
I mean, when at one point I was in a band called
Ten Fingers, not ten, but 10 like the Tin Man,
and there may be videos floating around
of some of some of our shows. That's the
only thing I can think of offhand.
Speaker 4: Interesting. Yeah. What
was your like style? But you guys play
Speaker 1: that was like alternative,
basically modern alternative.
Speaker 4: OK. Yeah, that's kind of cool. Yeah.
I'll look into that, yeah, 10 fingers. OK.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Thank
you so much for the call. Appreciate it.
Yeah, very, very powerful questions there.